[音楽]
こんな顔してます
あの最初はあのプロフィール写真をですね
の運営の方に出してくれって言われた時に
思わずいつも使ってる写真を出しちゃった
んですけどちょっとあのあそこに並んでる
ポスターを見るとあんまりにも違和感が
あってですねちゃんと普通の写真を出せば
よかったと後悔していた木のリハーサルの
時だったんですけど今日のテーマはいかに
も空は飛んでそうなタイトルなんですけど
もこのドローンを使った長官地点を
機械を使ってドローンという機械を使って
自分の視点として自分の中に取り入れた時
に私がどのような風に思ったか
新しい
視点というか新しい視座を手に入れたん
ですよね今まで持ってなかったこれは皆
さんにも追加体験をしてもらって
自分に置き換えて考えてもらったりする
ようなそんな時間にしたいなというふうに
思っていますで本題に入りますが
私ですね
空撮は
趣味としてもやっていて
業務としてもやってます映像も同じなん
ですけれども
他にもいろんな趣味があって例えばこんな
こうアウトドアな感じで来てますけども
登山がものすごい好きで日本はあの
日本百名山のうち40名山ぐらいはまあ
言ってるんですかねあとは海外の山も結構
行っていて何だったらエベレストにも登っ
たことがあるんですけど
その他にもですねあの例えば料理がとても
好きですよくわかんないアジアの料理とか
つい先週もなんかアゼルバイジャンの料理
みたいなの作ってみてですね大失敗して
あの
処理するのがとても大変で3日ぐらい
かかったっていうのがあったんですけどま
あそんな感じで趣味に
非常に多くの時間を費やしてるんですが
特に10代20代とかそれぐらいの頃に
特に時間を使ってた趣味っていうのが旅行
なんですよね
で
本当にあのいろんなところ旅してたんです
よ
ドローン手にする前の話なんですが
目的は今思えば昔流行った言葉で自分探し
とかそんなようなことだったと思います
もっとなんかこうエモい感じで言えば何
だろうなまだ見るこう自分の約束の地を
探していたみたいないろんなところに行っ
てたんです世界中
最終的には見つかったんですよそれがどこ
かっていうのがあのスコットランドという
ところでした
イギリスのスポットなんですねそこにある
風景っていうのは
私は風景写真風景映像みたいのそういうの
が好きなので世界中もあってそういった
ところを撮ったりしてたんですけどまるで
まぁこの世の
果てを思わせるかのような風景なんですよ
ねここは本当に地球なのかと
あるいは地球の長い歴史を感じさせるよう
なそういうこう地球史を感じさせるような
地形だったりとかそういった
映像そういった場所であるわけです
あるいはすごく交量としていて人類が
とてもここで生存し続けるとは思えない
ような場所なんですよねとっても厳しい
環境なんですけどもただそんな場所でも
長い本当に古代からずっと続いてきた歴史
がこのスコットランドっていう国にはある
んです
人類の歴史がそこで紡がれてきたような
場所なんですよ
スコットランドの非常に素晴らしい歴史と
文化を持った国ですあの私はこの地球の
果てにある
スコットランドっていう国を旅してそこに
こう長く滞在することでこの後の人生観を
変えるような体験というのをしたんですよ
ねであの旅っていうのはあの人の価値観を
大きく変えていく人の価値観を大きく
アップデートさせるようなそういった
アクティビティであるのかなというふうに
思います
皆さんもぜひですね日本だけじゃなくて
世界に出てなんかいろんなもの見てほしい
んですよねこうそうすることで新しい資材
に立つきっかけみたいなものを掴んで
いただけたらなという風に思ってます
あのなんかこういう優馬を入れるとです
ちょっとテットっぽいんであの1枚入れて
みたんですけどなんかあんまりこうなんか
そんな感じではないんで
1回やってみたかったんですねあの笑う
とこですんでここはちょっとあの笑って
いただければ幸いなんですけどあの
もちろんこれで終わりではなくてねそれで
皆さんに一言一つお聞きしたいんですあの
さっきスコットランドの話をしてる時に
なんかスライドの写真におかしなところが
あるなと思ってそれに気づいた方って
いらっしゃいますかねあの手とか上げなく
ていいんで分かったよみたいな人いたら
こう頷いていただけるとありがたいんです
けど
誰も頷かないってことはわかんなかったん
ですかねありがとうございますあの僕は
このスライドを入れて本当に良かったです
でこの辺の写真ですねさっきお見せした
写真なんですけど
熱くまあ旅について彼かかって語って言わ
れたわけなんですが
実はこの右側の写真ですね
全部北海道の写真なんですよありがとう
ございますあの
左上から
幌延町にあるサロベツ原野っていうところ
の空撮の写真ですね
右側が
新得町にある
トムラウシと山の上の写真で
右下がこれ東川町の朝日岳の冬の写真です
ねで最後は室蘭市のこれ地球岬っていう
ところです
ついでに言えばあの私あのアジアには
いろいろ行ってるんですけども
スコットランドのところがヨーロッパに足
を踏み入れたことがなくてですねあの
さっき喋ってたことは全部旅行ガイドに
書いてあったこと違うちらっとこうつまん
だだけで
習ったらさっき出してた写真も
クリエイティブコモンズフリー素材です
ありがとうございます
で
なんでこんな話をしたのかとあの皆さん
笑っていただきつつも頭にハテナが浮かん
でると思うんですけどあのこれらの写真を
見てどう認知するんか何を感じたかって
いうことを話したいんですよね
例えばあの私の視点をさっき
スコットランといえば地球の果てであり
ますよって話をしたんですけどまあ
アジア人から見て地球の果てっていうのを
北欧だったりとかそういったところなわけ
ですよ
スコットランドアイスランド
ででただこれをこう
北海道の写真を
スコットランドと見て思ってみるとまあ
そう見えてくるかもしれないとただでも
これは紛れもなく北海道の写真なわけです
我々が今生きてたり
学んでたりする場所にある
写真なんですよ
そういうふうに認証認識をした時にまあ
感じることってやっぱり違うよねって話を
したいんですね
でそれは何かって話を掘り下げていきます
けども
自分の立場が何か変わったりとか
気持ちの
内面の気持ちが変わった時に大きく
価値観がガラッと変わって気分が変わる
ような瞬間ってあると思うんですよ皆さん
経験あると思いますそこで皆さんにもう一
つ問いかけてみたいんですが人間の年を
取るとですね
誰もが哲学者になるみたいな
ことって聞いたことないですかね
結構あのちょっとライトが明るくて見え
ないんですけど歳いってる方多いような気
するんですけど
なんか30代を超えると
みんなこう人生について考え出す瞬間
みたいのがあると思うんですよもちろん
若い方ももちろんあるかもしれないんです
けど年を取るとただよりそれが鮮明にです
ねより強いギャップを持って
考えちゃうわけですですると
例えば何かこう社会活動みたいなところに
より強くこう踏み出していったりとかあと
割と重い転職をしてみたりとかあとはです
ねこちらに前と書いてますけど
急にあの前の修行を始めたりとか
マインドフルネスの勉強し始めたりとかっ
ていうことをし始めたりするわけです
あるいは急に山とか森とか
自然に関心を持ち始めたりとかでそれが
なんでそうなるかっていうと
甲府とあの人生哲学みたいな目覚めるん
ですよねあの私はこの短い人生100年
ぐらいしかない短い人生の中で何をなす
べきなんだろうなということを
狭間に向かってこう自分の心の中で叫び
出すわけですよでもちろん私もその一人で
急にまあ山の割とハードコアなところに
登ったりしてるんですよね
でそれでそのうち何かガツンとした出来事
がいっぱいあるのなんですけどこれがあっ
てこの答えに折り合いをつけるんですこの
ドローンと出会って私はですねかつ変わっ
たんですよじゃあ空撮は私にどんな影響を
もたらしたのかなと
色々考えて思いついたのがこちらです
ゴッドビューと
体操なもの
スライドなんですけどあのもうドローンを
通じた長官支点っていうのはこれあの人間
の視点ではなくて今で人間が持ちえなかっ
た視点なんですよね
でイコール召喚視点を僕は神の視点だと
思ってますちょっと大げさに聞こえるかも
しれないんですけど
言ってみれば
究極の客観視点ですねあの
マインドフルネスの世界とか精神的な世界
でこういった言葉がよくあるんですけども
そういう意味じゃなくて
ドローンという非常にフィジカルなもの
機械を通じて
実際のその視点を
自分のが手にすることができる今自分が
立っている場所の
過去とか未来とかそういったものに思いを
させて
支給紙とか人類史みたいなものをより近い
短く身近に感じることができるこれが
捉えるようになったら
自分の視座っていうものを大きくやっぱり
変わって
価値観がアップデートされて私はメニス
するものに認知の仕方がガラッと変わ
るっていう体験をしました今回のせっかく
なのであの
皆さんにもできるだけ僕と同じ資材に立っ
てもらって残りの10分くらいですかね
あのお話ができたかなというふうに思って
います
今回の北海道大学っていうことで私が取っ
てきた北海道の空撮映像をまとめてみまし
たのでこちらの方をご紹介をさせて
ください
[音楽]
[拍手]
非常に
非常に短い
映像だったんですけどもあのお見せした
映像の撮影場所はまあ激励マークの
テロップも出てましたが北海道です全部
北海道ですねでだいたいの北海道なんでも
ないような場所から空撮映えしそうな場所
っていうのを探して私が取ってきたんです
けどもまあ
本当にあのこう観光地でも何でもないよう
な場所なんですよただでもこうも
ドラマチックに見えると何かこう壮大な
ストーリーを感じさせるような一つ一つの
映像のカットっていうのがあの撮れてい
ました
ねこの写真ですねサロ別原野です先ほど1
枚ちょっと小さく見せましたけどもちろん
これも私が撮ったものなんですが
何かこう地球を管理させる壮大な1枚の
ように見えませんかねあの地平線の彼方
まで広がる原野ともっと天気がやったら奥
に利尻島が見えるんですけどもあのただ
この写真ですね特に観光地で撮ったって
わけではなくて
差別原野というところは国立公園ではある
んですが年間に観光客は50人ぐらいしか
来ないようなあの何でもないようなとこな
んですよあとついでに言えば僕の実家の
近くでですねこの撮った場所から300m
ぐらい先に僕の実家があります
で
子供の頃とかは僕ここでよく遊んでたん
ですけど
子供の頃にあのこんな風景が自分のがいる
ところの空中から見えるなんて思って
なかったんですよねでただ僕が遊んでた
ような場所から空中に100メートル
ぐらい開けただけの場所にこんな壮大な
景色が広がっていたんですよこの
ゴッドビューで世界を見
るっていうのはそういうことに気づかせて
もらえるとあのこの素晴らしい視点に
気づいた時から
特に私はですね
北海道の様々なところを回って空撮の映像
を撮りまくってきました
山の中とか森の中とかあとは何かの
産業以降とかですねそういったところを
取りまくりましたが
いざその場所に立ってですね
実際取り始めるともう撮影ができない
ぐらいなぜか手が震え出すっていう瞬間が
あったんですよでそれがなぜ何かっていう
のに
考えた時にいいことが今一つなの出てます
けど大体の場所においてあの映像として
ですね初めて世に出るものだったんですよ
ねあの実はダイバー後になってから気づい
たんですけど
例えばGoogleとかで検索しても一向
に参考になるような資料っていうのは出て
こないんですよね
図書館とかに行ってあの古い明治時代の人
が書いてある北海道の開拓記の文書みたい
な見たら
確かにここに何かがあった場所そこを見た
人そこに訪れて何かを見たっていう人の
記述とかがあったりするんですけど
いわゆる
デジタルコンテンツとかメディア
コンテンツとして一切そこに何を何もない
ような場所だったんですよ
っていうのは地上から見た見てもこう草が
モサモサ生えてるだけで何がそこにあるの
かわからないような場所
地形なんてやっぱり見えないわけですよね
ただそれがやっぱり空撮で見ると全然違う
風景っていうかそこに広がっていて
そういったこう過去の人は誰かは確かに
訪れてる場所だったのかもしれないんです
けどただ空撮とか映像化をされたことは
一切ないといわゆる人類未到の
クリエイティブみたいなものにチャレンジ
をしていたんだっていうことを
後になってからずいぶんあとになってから
気づいたんですこのあの感動にうち震えて
いたんですよね
冒頭でもお伝えした通りそして
感じた感動っていうのはやがて私が感じて
た大きな狭間にこう橋をかけていくことに
なりますここ数年日本だけじゃなくて世界
的にもいろんな暗い話題があるたくさん
あると思うんですが
僕ももっとそんな社会にですね
自分をこう役立てていくというかもっと
強いコミットしていくために何かできない
のかなっていうのずっと考えてたんです
30代に入ってそんな中僕はドローンに
出会ってより世界を強く積み上げる
クリエイティブとして
空撮っていうものがここにあったんだと
いうことに気づきました
ねただこれではまだ私の認知をですね
アップデートさせるような体験ではなかっ
たわけなんですよねただこのすごい凄さを
うざいくらいこう周りの人に語り続けてい
たら不思議なご縁をいただくことができ
ました
あの当時は2017年ですねあの
来年まあ2018年北海道の有名150年
を迎えるっていうタイミングだったんです
がこの中でこのオデッセイという映像作品
を作る機会をいただけまして
これ何かっていうと
北海道過去に探検した松浦武四郎さんと
いう方がいますこの人が
映像日誌という文書に残した場所っていう
のを実際自分の足で訪れてみてそこを空撮
して回るその様子をドキュメンタリーに
するっていう映像作品ですあのいろんな
ところで賞をいただけてこの写真は
先月の
札幌国際キャンペーンが祭での写真なん
ですけれども大なり小なりいろんな賞を
いただくことができました
でその中で
海外の映画祭でもらったオランダだったと
思うんですが
好評でこんなものがありました
この短い言葉じゃなくて結構長い好評
いただいたんですけども
要約するとこんな感じでしたあの初めて見
た時ちょっと目の鱗が落ちたんですよね
あの
世界の果てだと思っていた場所から見て
みればやっぱり日本っていう場所は世界の
果てなんだなっていうあの
あんまりこう
一気には当たり前のことなんですけどそう
なんですよそもそも
ヨーロッパの人とかって北海道のっていう
場所とかそこにどういう風景が広がってる
かなんて認知してないんですよねそれを
知ってもらった時に
すごい感動してもらえたっていう体験をし
ましたで私最初にあの約束の地っていう話
をしたんですけどこの約束の地っていう
概念あの言い換えれば自分探しの終着点
みたいなものなんですがこれって人が持つ
色んな属性によって変わるもんだと思うん
ですねあのアジアに人にとっては
ヨーロッパの端っこかもしれないしその逆
もしっかりであるいは両方からも
両方の人からすれば南極とか北極とか
宇宙とか海底とかあるいは未来とか過去と
かそういったものかもしれないです
あるいは日本国内からこうした映像を見せ
た時の
反応あの
地元の人って
結構ね自分の地元って何もないみたいな
ことを言いがちだと思うんですよねあの僕
が空撮して回っていろんな人に話を聞いて
回るといや俺の街は何もねえから空から
取れとこなんでなんもないんだよみたいな
ことを言われがちでした
確かに何もないわけです行ってみるとただ
でも空撮して見てたらあの私がさっき持っ
たような感動っていうのはみんな持って
もらえたっていう瞬間がありましたあの
海外と国内の話しましたが
海外向けば感動を持ってその場を認知して
いただけたことあの国連向きで言えばそう
した感動を持って何かこう再発見でしょし
てもらうような機会をもらえたことこの2
つの体験を持って私はいくつかの気づきを
確信に変えることができましたその話を
次の説明ですね1つが人側も身障風景のさ
これには大きな差があって
例えばそれはすごく買いがたいものなんだ
けれども
立場や属性が違えば強く心に響く響かせ方
伝わり方どうやって伝えればいいかって
いうことが
異なるよって話を
話ですで
故に今伝え方とか何を伝えるかはよくよく
考えなければいけなくてその
伝え方っていうところに空撮っていうもの
がとても刺さるんだっていうことにこれは
確信を持ちましたねっていう話が2つ目
です
空撮が持つクリエイティブとしての価値と
私はクリエティブっていうのは人やものが
人やものを繋いだりとかより深い思考を
促したりするようなものだと思ってるん
ですが
空撮っていうのはそれは世界繋げる新たな
視点として最高のものだということに確信
を持ちました
価値を再発見するということですねこれも
先ほどちょっと触れたんですが
昔は文書とか絵巻物が最先端のコンテンツ
だったわけなんですよただ今は写真とか
映像とかデジタルコンテンツです
昔はまあ
例えば
そこに想像を巡らせた
SFみたいなものだったんですけど
映像にしてみるとこれはドキュメンタリー
になるんですよね人はもっとリアリティを
持ってその場を認知したりとか
感動してもらえたりする
ドローン使えば今ある風景にそういう新た
な付加価値が
付けられると
価値が入って再発見して最高の
クリエイティブに生まれ変わらせることが
できるそういう人に気づいた時に私を
大きく認知がアップデートされました
言い換えれば
狭間は最初からなかったっていうことに
気づいたんですよね視点を変えたりとか
何か機械を使ってそういう視点を変える
ことができて
実はそこに何もなくて
こういう方っていうのはいくらでもあった
とそれは私はドローンでした人間は内面の
態度を変えることで人生周辺にある
環境を変えることができると
ウィリアムジェームスさんっていう哲学者
の言葉なんですけどもあのよくスポーツの
世界とかでも言われる言葉です
保守的に取られるような今の話ではあるん
ですがあの人間の認知が変わって
価値観が一変する様を強く言い表した言葉
であるように思います
ドが出会うことで
内面の態度を大きく変えるっていう
きっかけを得ることができましたあの皆
さんに置き換えてもらってそれはどの
みたいに何かのテクノロジーとの出会いか
もしれないし何か心理的な発見かもしれ
ないし何が自分で取り組んでる人もいるか
もしれないしこれからの人もいるかもしれ
ません
今日のプレゼンテーションがそういった
ことに何かつながればいいなというふうに
思っていますそうすれば僕がここに正して
いただいた意味もあるんじゃないのかなと
いうふうに思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]